hi I'm Evan Carmichael and today I
wanted to do a quick video to answer a
question from one of our readers in oral
I hope I pronounced that properly his
business is in the management training
and consulting and he has one staff
member named who is a personal assistant
and he's looking to grow his business by
hiring a couple salespeople his question
is is wondering if a commission only
sales model would work for him and if it
makes sense
so Commission only sales models can be
great and this is basically what you're
not paying a salary to your salespeople
and they're out selling it's great for
performance only so you're only giving
up money when money's coming in but you
have to remember that it does take time
for salesperson to get revved up so you
might want to consider doing a draw at
the beginning so they get paid a certain
amount of salary until they start
earning Commission just so that they
don't get discouraged and quit on you
too soon you put a lot of time and
effort into training and then they're
gone
so consider paying a base until they
start making some Commission coming in
you also might think about trying to
generate leads for them one of the
things that says we really hate doing is
generating leads at the start it's a lot
easier once you can generate tasks and
leads for them they can go out and close
the sales so if you're going to provide
any kind of support for them if it's
email marketing or telemarketing or the
direct mail or your website anything
that can help support them get started
and quickly learn how to get in there
and sell your product that's a lot
easier to start attracting some good
sales people to your company and a lot
easier to penny of the Commission a link
model so I hope that helps a lot hiring
the two salespeople and let us know how
it goes if people enjoyed this video
please leave a comment below I'd love to
hear your thoughts and feedback and the
thumbs up too and you'll stay tuned for
the next video
you